all right
um hi everyone thanks for the invitation
it's great to be here
we're going to talk about a topic that
is fairly new to me but has some
connections
throughout this Workshop
um so this was worked with a number of
collaborators and in particular I want
to give a shout out to the students who
worked on this
who visited us from Singapore
Charlie who's in the audience today and
try Chi
so data valuation is an area of research
that tries to study or propose metrics
for evaluating how much data is worth
and there's a wide swath of literature
on this uh typically for the purpose of
Designing data markets so the idea is
that you would have users who are
contributing data who want to know how
much to pay them for their individual
data contributions in order to satisfy
certain properties
it's also used in the context of
interpretable machine learning to
identify the most important noisy or
misleading samples in some cases
um so these are some of the use cases
that are typically mentioned in context
of data values
but
um I believe the use cases for data
valuation are changing and evolving
so today there are a number of data
marketplaces that are emerging
that allow users to post their own data
sets so they choose their own price
and users go on these marketplaces and
choose which data sets they want to
purchase access to so examples include
AWS Marketplace snowflake data raid
and the observation about these data
marketplaces is that they typically
offer data previews to users so for
example if I want to purchase this data
set on vessel ownership
I could either pay seven thousand
dollars or I can check out a free sample
preview to decide if I want to purchase
this data set
a similar story plays out with a lot of
generative data vendors so a lot of
vendors today are selling access to a
generative model for example
Shutterstock is selling stock images
and here you can try a free sample so
you can see a few samples from their
generative model before you decide if
you want to pay for access to the
underlying data distribution essentially
so an important question that's closely
related to data evaluation is how should
a data user pick the data set that they
want to purchase or use in some cases
they're not explicitly purchasing it in
some cases the costs are implicit in
terms of what's needed to actually train
a model for example or conduct your
Downstream test
so existing data valuation literature
tends to be designed to Value only a
fixed data set so the effect is that we
don't have theoretical guarantees on
using the valuation of a particular data
set in order to actually value the
underlying distribution which is what
we're paying for
the second observation is that existing
techniques don't explicitly model or
analyze the fact that different data
sets are drawn from different
distributions
so oftentimes
they'll just compute a data valuation
metric without thinking about
necessarily thinking about what is the
underlying distribution that this was
drawn from which means we can't
theoretically account for the effects of
data heterogeneity whether that be due
to Natural Randomness or even
adversarial inputs from from a data
event
so in this work we have been starting to
consider a problem setting that looks
like the following we have n data
vendors each of whom has their own data
distribution P1 through PN
these data distributions can be
different from one another in general so
it's a heterogeneous data heterogeneous
setting
and each of those distributions has some
inherent value which I'm going to call
Epsilon
this value is unknown to basically
anyone but we're going to try to
estimate it
so from these distributions what the
user actually does have access to is a
sample data set this is like the preview
that I told you about earlier
so we sample a data set from each of
these distributions I'm using notation a
bit here saying D the data set D is
drawn from the distribution P1 and these
are M IID samples for each of these
distributions
now from these distributions we can
compute a data set valuation which I'll
denote new
all right now the data user which is all
of us going on to you know snowflake
Marketplace to purchase a data set or
access to a data stream
is going to look at these data set
valuations and try to determine which of
the data vendors should I purchase from
in other words we want to choose a
distribution valuation function Epsilon
and a data set valuation new
so that the data user can identify the
most useful data vendor based only on
the sample data sets that they have
accessed
now of course the key question is how do
we actually Define this distributional
utility what does that even mean
and two
nail down this this problem statement a
little bit more carefully we're going to
make an additional assumption
which is that we have access or no we
don't have access to but there exists a
reference distribution P star
so this is representing the underlying
distribution for the downstream use case
that the data user has so for example if
they're trying to train a model for
their own Enterprise or whatever P star
would be the distribution of their
clients data
we assume that this exists we do not
assume that we have access to it
and what we're going to do in our model
is to think about these data vendors as
as following a Huber model with respect
to this P star which is to say there
exists some contamination distribution Q
and the obser the distribution P that
the vendor actually draws from is going
to be some mixture of this contamination
Cube and the reference distribution P
star
so formally we'll write this as uh p is
a mixture Epsilon Q times 1 minus
Epsilon P star so here the larger
Epsilon is the closer we are to Q
now in the context of this earlier
problem statement
um or earlier model we're going to have
these n different data vendors and each
of them can have an a different
contamination distribution in general
and each of them can also have a
different degree of contamination a
different episode
so I know
vendors could be at different points
along this along
so now if we go back to this statement
of what we want we're trying to design a
or choose a distribution valuation
function Epsilon that is somehow
measuring each vendor's closeness to the
reference distribution P star
we're going to choose this as a distance
measure between distributions between p
and PC
and in particular we want to choose this
Epsilon and new in such a way that we
can get theoretical bounds on how
different should the data set valuations
be in order to conclude that the
underlying distribution was also better
and we want that dependence to be
explicit in the sample size M and the
heterogeneity levels the Epsilon
there's a number of questions that we
need to figure out the first one of
course is what what distance measure
Upsilon should we use
the second is once we've defined Epsilon
or specified it what valuation new
should we choose
third is how do we approximate the
reference distribution P star because as
I mentioned earlier we don't have access
to that nobody has access to it it just
exists
and fourth is how does data
heterogeneity affect our data valuation
so let's start with the first question
what distance measure should we use
so the intuition here is is pretty
simple the intuition is that the closer
we are to P star the more valuable the
data set should or the data distribution
should be so in this picture
I would prefer P2 to P1 because it is
closer to P star
so we're going to restrict ourselves to
some kind of statistical Divergence
between probability distributions some
measure of distance between them
we're just going to take the negative
because I want a higher valuation to
correspond to a closer closer data sets
now here there's a yes
why not DP star p
sh um
so in general
uh I'm not going to require that these
be let this be symmetric because P star
is playing a kind of an asymmetric role
in in this whole setup
so I'm going to allow this to
potentially be
an asymmetric measure so P star I just
arbitrarily set it
so when we are trying to choose what
kind of Divergence should we use
um this question starts to look a lot
like a question that we ask in the
design of generative adversarial methods
so basically we're trying to measure
distance between two distributions based
on samples
um and in that literature there's been a
lot of discussion on what distance
measure to use so a lot of work has
looked at using active agencies
so F divergences here are measuring the
distance between these distributions p
and p Star by looking at the ratio of
these two densities when they exist
integrating over the over the space
now and some very well-known examples of
f divergences include kale Divergence
total variations
um and these techniques are very widely
used in the in the data valuation
literature
a second class that has gotten a lot of
traction in the gam literature is
integral probability metrics ipms
and these metrics take the approach of
instead measuring the distance between
these distributions by looking at the
difference
rather than looking at the ratio and
this has the nice property that even if
these two distributions are not defined
on the same support we can still get we
can still get numbers that make sense
so notable examples include the
vassarstine one distance and the maximum
indiscretes
so a lot of Prior works on valuation
have focused on F divergences for their
nice theoretical properties
so some of the benefits include a clear
information theoretic interpretation
especially for KL divergences for
example
and they're also used often to prove
some kind of incentive compatibility so
remember I said earlier that data
valuation is often used to analyze
um
data markets so you have different users
who are trying to
um who are reporting their data and
wanting to get some payment for that
data so a lot of the prior work that
uses tail divergences or information
theoretic measures are showing that some
kind of Nash equilibrium like you're
incentivized to report your data
correctly
but of course there are also some
drawbacks which is that
um these f divergences are notoriously
difficult to estimate from samples
especially as your dimension increases
so we often in practice require
variational representation structures
and a lot of the prior work on using
these divergences require strong
distributional assumptions
so in particular the assumption that the
data vendor's distribution P should be
absolutely continuous with respect to P
star
and this in general will not hold in a
data Marketplace
data sharing study
you could you could get on this by using
symmetrics
yeah that's true that's true but the the
estimate estimation properties are still
estimation is still challenging and
still have this property that
um
if the supports are not people the the
numbers are not as meaningful as several
weeks
so um
yeah so as I mentioned this is a similar
discussion to what we've seen with
regarding Gans and integral probability
metrics are widely used today for
estimating distributional distances from
examples we saw this in the in a very
nice keynote this morning um
Professor steam cans
so uh in this work we looked at using an
IPM for doing this data valuation task
which is maximum mean discrepancy MMD
so the MMD was initially proposed as a
two-sample test for determining if two
sets of samples come from the same
distribution or not
briefly it's defined as follows as an
expression on the screen so this first
term is evaluating the kernel on pairs
of samples from the same distribution p
this middle term is is evaluating the
kernel on pairs of samples from being
drawn from p and Q
and the last term is evaluating the
kernel on pairs of samples all drawn
from the same distribution
and um so the the proposed distribution
valuation function that we would like to
use is the negative MMD between P which
is the vendor's data distribution and P
star which is our reference distribution
and we'll see that this choice of
Upsilon of uh distribution valuation has
some important implications down the
line
so given that let's fix that for now how
do we estimate this from samples well
here again we have a very easy answer
which is that there exists nice
estimators for the MMD
so for example there exists a biased
estimator from the work of gretton and
collaborators
that basically replaces the expectations
in our in our earlier definition with
empirical needs
and in particular the reason we like
this estimator is because it comes with
uniform convergence bounds
so in particular let's suppose that we
have two data sets D and D Prime which
are drawn from p and p Prime
respectively
then this biased MMD estimator D hat
satisfies the following to parse this so
this first term is the distance between
the estimated and the true MMD so the
estimated based on samples and the true
based on the distribution
this term depends on our sample size m
and this beta is just some some bias
that we can control
and we see that this is decaying
exponentially fast in beta squared and
in M the number of samples
so what's nice about this is that this
does not depend on problem dimension
this means that even as our data
Dimension grows we still get these nice
convergence properties
and that's really important for these
kinds of problems
um
so
yes
samples from each or so in general we
can assume that we have arbitrary number
of samples from each I just set them
both to M to make this expression
simpler but and in your work do you
assume you have samples from P star or
we do not assume we have samples from P
star but actually a huge number of
papers in this space do assume that we
have a sample samples from P star which
I think is not a realistic assumption so
we try to get around that in this work
um so sorry this is a typo this should
be the negative D half m and d but the
point is for question two we're going to
estimate our distribution valuation by
using this estimator that already exists
um and applying and for now
let's suppose that we can apply it to D
star which is a data set that's drawn
from the reference P star the practice
we don't have it so in the next question
I'll I'll tell you about how we get
around this
all right so the third question is how
do we approximate this reference D Star
as I mentioned a lot of works just say
well let's let's suppose we have it but
in reality we don't and so what we do
have is these vendors who are drawing
from some distribution P1 through p n
we don't have D start
so the vendors are
exposing their data sets D1 through DN
so what we're going to do is use a very
natural estimate of the star which is to
take the union of all of these data sets
except for the iPhone when we're valuing
the ice data set
so so if I'm trying to value my data set
I'm going to take the union of everybody
else's data as an approximation of B
Star
and accordingly we can write a
probability distribution P bar of
negative I that is some linear
combination of all of these other pis
and what's nice about the Huber model of
heterogeneity that I introduced earlier
is that this can be written itself as
another Huber model with a different
Epsilon I bar and Qi bar
so
um and the relevance of this will come
back in just a second
so the proposed reference data set that
we would like to use here is that
instead of using D star we're going to
use D Bar negative I
know it's the union of all of the data
sets except the iPhone
so finally let's ask how does data
heterogeneity affect our valuation
so here recall that we're using for our
distribution valuation the MMD based
valuation
and uh we are also assuming a Huber
model so
um under those two circumstances we can
draw on a very recent work by Sheriff
Abdullah
and
um
which shows that the mm that our data
evaluation can be written as the
negative of Epsilon which was our
outlier probability
times the MMD from the outlier
distribution to the reference
distribution
this gives a very clear and
interpretable understanding of how
heterogeneity affects
our distributional data valuation and
then we can use our estimator to
translate that into guarantees for
example for the samples that we observe
um so
these are the answers to the four
questions that I initially posed so now
let's take a look at the main result
so suppose we're given data sets Di and
DJ drawn from PI and PJ
and we have a reference data set so for
Di this would look like D Bar negative I
as I mentioned earlier
uh this result is a little hairy so
let's parse it
um step by step let's start at the
bottom actually so this is what the
buyer wants the buyer wants to know if
the utility of Pi is greater than the
utility of PJ by some threshold row
that at least row better is pi at least
row better than PJ
now what the buyer sees is this
inequality so it's allowed to see the
valuation on the actual sample data set
so new of di is greater than new of DJ
by some threshold Delta
we're saying that if that Delta is at
least
this large
which has three terms first is the
desired margin row
second is the error from the estimator
that I talked about earlier which
depends on sample size and parameter
beta
and the third is this dependence on
heterogeneity that I mentioned earlier
then we can conclude in fact that the
distribution Pi is better than the
distribution PGA lesson
so I wanted to give just an example of
how this result might be used and where
it fails
so going back to the examples I showed
earlier
um here this is a screenshot from data
raid okay sorry it's not showing up very
well on the screen
but this is an example from a data set
that offers a data preview
now typically these data previews are on
the order of like 10 to 20 samples
they're not that big
so if the data buyer wants to ensure
that the valuation on data set I is
greater than the valuation on data set J
by at least some Delta this was the
expression for Delta that we had earlier
let's just plug in some kind of back of
the envelope numbers
I'm going to choose 0 for all of the
parameters except for the sample size
just to make this as favorable to the to
the data set as possible
and we get a Delta of 2.5
now notice that under our assumptions
the MMD is not going to be ever larger
than two because we've assumed that our
kernel is bounded
um so this means that for these small
M's either our bound is too loose to be
able to say anything or these providers
should be providing actually more data
to allow users to evaluate the
difference between data sets
um and you know just intuitively 10
samples doesn't seem like enough to make
any kind of quantitative evaluation of
whether one data set is better than
another so I would be inclined to think
that it's it would be useful for these
data vendors to provide larger preview
data sets
um
so I also wanted to show some empirical
results
um
for this data valuation metric this MMD
based evaluation metric so to look at
this we constructed some synthetic
scenarios where we started with a
reference data set P star which is the
mnist data set
then we picked a contamination data set
Q which is feminist
and what we're going to do is construct
a sequence of databases That Vary
Epsilon between 0 and 1. so we know
intuitively that the smaller Epsilon is
the more valuable that data set should
be because it's closer to um to P star
so we know the true ranking of our
databases of our data sets and that's
going to be this Zeta vector
then we're going to compute valuations
from sample data sets and what we want
is that our computed valuation should
correlate in rank with the true
valuation the ground truth which we know
so we computed the Pearson correlation
here between these two ranked lists and
want this to be as close to one as
possible
so what we saw is that for both under
this Huber model and under other models
of heterogeneity and contamination the
MMD was better able to rank these data
sets
than than prior valuation techniques
now in the last few minutes I wanted to
discuss a topic that's kind of related
to some of the earlier talks what if we
also want a differential privacy
so in particular what if we had one data
set that we're trying to Value against
um that is should be private
let's revisit the MMD estimator so this
was the expression from before now these
red terms are the ones that depend on
our private data
and the thing I want you to notice about
this
is that if I swap out one record from
the data set D Prime
these terms are going to could
potentially change a lot so they have
high sensitivity
they could affect up to M different
terms in this submission for each of
them
so because these terms have high
sensitivity means we would need to add a
lot of noise which means this isn't
necessarily a great candidate for
differential prices
so in some recent work
um Charlie and some collaborators from
meta have been looking at a related data
valuation scenario from the Federated
learning context
so the setting here is slightly
different the idea is that we have a
reference data set P star but it's split
across a bunch of different Federated
clients
so that's our our reference
and the central server holds a few
different pre-training data sets for a
model that they want to ultimately
fine-tune on the Federated client's data
so the question is which of these
pre-training data sets should we choose
to best match the distributed Federated
data distribution
um
so
um because of some of the shortcomings
that I that we saw earlier with the nmd
in this work we looked at the for shade
distance which is commonly used to
evaluate generative adversarial networks
and other genitive models
and we can see that for gaussian
distributions this crochet distance
takes a very simple closed form
expression
so here again the red terms are the ones
that depend on our private data
and what we can see is that this
expression only depends on the private
mean and covariance of the Federated
client's data unfortunately this is
something that we can estimate easily we
can just have each client add
distributed noise and aggregate all of
their all of their data all of their
estimates of these parameters
so
empirically we can get a differentially
private estimate of data valuations and
we showed empirically that these data
valuations can be used to distinguish
very similar data sets and can be also
used to predict Downstream performance
on Federated learning tasks like test
accuracy
so this plot is showing you an
experiment where we had three
candidate pre-training data sets which
were held at the central server
and our reference data set which was
supposed to be held by the Federated
clients was a stack Overflow data set
so our three candidates were some
mixtures of stack overflow with Wiki
text so wikitex was like our uh
contamination distribution
um and so what we wanted was to conclude
that the candidate pre-training data set
that consists 100 of stack Overflow is
the best one has the smallest distance
and so here on the horizontal axis I'm
showing you the percentage of the data
set that is stack Overflow so basically
this is the one that's closest to the
reference data set and so we want this
distance to be smallest
in fact we can see that first of all it
is smallest and second it's able to
distinguish even with very strong
differential privacy parameters it's
able to distinguish between a data set
that is 100 stack Overflow and 99 stack
overflow
so this suggests that maybe in practice
we could use some kind of DP estimates
of of data data value or data similarity
to choose data sets to
precede or pre-trained models prior to
Federated learning
so to summarize
um I think that data selection is an
important use case for data valuation
and
um this use case can drive certain
desiderata that aren't necessarily
analyzed typically in the data valuation
literature
including confidence guarantees on when
to choose one data vendor over another
as well as privacy guarantees
so
um I think that MMD can be a useful tool
for data valuation but there's no
fundamental reason why it should be only
MMD so there could be other measures
that are equally good and give us
similar kinds of guarantees
um and I think one really interesting
open question is to understand if there
are trade-offs between
valuation and privacy and how to choose
what distance metric to use I think
these are really uh this is a kind of a
messy space there's a lot going on and I
think there's a lot of room to ask
interesting questions around the
trade-offs between data valuation and
privacy
thank you all for your attention
[Applause]
very nice talk from the point of view of
the person putting their data or selling
their data on the Market's place they
also have an incentive to disclose as
little data as possible so how would
that fit into your model is there some
kind of equilibrium point from like
disclosing enough data so someone
perceives a high valuation and my and
how my my valuation decreases as I
disclose more samples
yeah that's a that's a great point in
particular you are incentivized to share
fewer samples if your data is bad
so yeah I think that's a really
interesting point and would be a nice
way to enrich the model uh we didn't
analyze that or think about it at all
but I think you're very right
I mean actually to kind of piggyback on
that I saw some I've never seen a paper
on it but I saw work on trying to
identify e hacking by or like identify
people uh
basically your incentive but like you're
really going to share a lot of data then
you can
get less likely
the largest size of the data that you're
sharing
there's
but you can you can infer How likely it
is that's very interesting I would love
to I think I'll talk to you later I'd
love to get that paper
another question let's take this
[Applause]
hour and a half break
a break